So, there are a lot of
open source systems for
different aspects of monitoring.
This is a really vast subject, so
we can't really cover all of it.
Couple of important points, one you
won't be able to monitor every aspect
of your system with only a single tool.
That's okay.
Pick a couple.
It's important though that whatever
monitoring systems you pick be
generally accessible within
your organization so
that other people can
learn from them as well.
One of the most flexible
approaches to monitoring
involves having some kind
of key value data store,
with a simple API to dump in
whatever values you want to monitor.
This is the approach favored by
Graphite, InfluxDB, etcetera.
Then you have various front
ends to visualize the data.
Graphite offers it's
own web front end for
it's data, Graphite also works well for
a more flexible display.
And there are a lot
of other systems that
are mentioned in the instructor notes.
Now for the app server you've
been working within this class,
we've provided a Graphite monitoring
server with symmetric setup.
You should check it out.